hello and welcome to med simplified
diabetes is nothing less than a pandemic
in 2003 194 million people suffer from
diabetes and by 2025
this number is projected to increase by
72 percent
to
333 million
in 2016 an estimated 1.6 million deaths
were directly caused by diabetes which
makes diabetes the seventh leading cause
of death in 2016.
diabetes affects persons of all ages and
races the disease reduces both a
person's quality of life and life
expectancy and imposes a large economic
burden on the health care system and on
the families
diabetes is a metabolic disease
characterized by hyperglycemia which is
excessive concentration of glucose in
your blood this is due to a defect in
the beta cells of your pancreas which
secrete insulin or it can be a defect at
the cellular level which the receptors
can have and they do not react properly
to the insulin
this persistently high sugar in the
blood affects virtually every organ in
your body and it leads to various
problems like heart attacks strokes
irreversible nerve damage ulcers that
don't heal severe infections retinal
damage leading to permanent blindness
and kidney failure
a pregnant female with diabetes is at an
increased risk of abortions and serious
complications
now your diet plays an important role in
managing diabetes one reason is that the
food you eat on a day to day basis has a
direct impact on your blood sugar levels
for instance high carb foods raise your
blood sugar levels the digestive system
breaks down the digestible ones into
sugar which enters a blood but then
again not all carbohydrates are bad
complex carbohydrates like whole grains
take longer to digest while simple carbs
like white flour and refined sugars may
cause sudden spikes in your blood sugar
levels
indian foods are deeply rooted in
history and are probably one of the
oldest foods known to mankind
traditional indian foods are extremely
diverse just as its geography many
stable foods species and vegetables in
the indian diet are very good for people
with diabetes
so in this video we will be discussing
five such traditional indian foods that
have been scientifically proven to have
health benefits for people suffering
from diabetes
number one barley
a study done by a university in sweden
states that eating a special mixture of
dietary fibers found in barley can help
reduce your appetite as well as high
blood sugar levels
whole grains like oats brown rice or
millets like jar or ragi contain both
soluble and insoluble fiber that helps
with sugar control number 2 bitter guard
also known as karela
bitter guard contains an insulin-like
compound called polypeptide p or p
insulin which has been shown to control
diabetes naturally a report issued in
the journal of chemistry and biology
gives evidence that consumption of
bitter guard tends to increase the
uptake of glucose in the cells and
improves glycemic control
number three amla also known as
gooseberry
amla also known as indian gooseberry is
a traditional remedy to control high
blood sugar levels it also contains the
mineral chromium which regulates
carbohydrate metabolism and helps in
making your body more responsive to
insulin
number four fenugreek also known as
methi
a study published in the international
journal of vitamin and nutrition
research found that a daily dose of 10
grams of fenugreek seeds soaked in hot
water helps to control type 2 diabetes
fenugreek water has the ability to lower
blood sugar in people with diabetes it
contains fiber and helps in slowing down
the digestion process further regulating
the absorption of carbohydrates and
sugar
the fenugreek water also helps in
improving the way your body uses sugar
the number five and the last food that
we have are beans
beans contain a healthy dose of fiber
nutrients and protein keeping us full
for a longer time and reducing our
carbohydrate intake a low glycemic index
effectively reduces blood sugar level
beans are an excellent source of
vegetable protein and are extremely
beneficial for diabetics a cup of beans
or lentils each day combined with a low
glycemic diet was shown to lower blood
sugar levels and coronary artery risk
disease in patients with type 2 diabetes
so friends these were the 5 best types
of foods that you should include in your
diet if you have diabetes make sure to
subscribe to our channel so that you
don't miss out on our upcoming videos
about diabetes health we will discuss
about the precautions you should take if
you have diabetes best types of
exercises for people with diabetes and
much more
i hope you found this video helpful if
you did make sure to hit the like button
below to support us you can also support
me simplified by clicking the join
button below or joining our page at
patreon.com thank you so much for
watching see you in the next video